comme maintenant on passe à l'interview
nul les choristes à al arabiya
boc ont bougé pendant le jingle daniel
prévost rivasi interview mule êtes vous
favorable à la paix dans le monde
bah oui bien sûr pourquoi pourquoi
certains venus d'accord c'est bien un
concept à des morceaux très fort après
tu les fais toi même extrêmement bien
sûr car ce genre de trucs alors je vais
te dire elles sont à chier tu as rien
alors
bayrou à 10 secondes après une
catastrophe atomique
il ne reste sur terre qu'un homme c'est
vous et trois femmes laquelle
choisissez-vous pour repeupler la
planète parmi attention martine aubry
michèle alliot marie ou dominique voynet
avec laquelle décidez vous de repeupler
la planète
je pense pas que la planète ait besoin
de se repeupler
si vous étiez le fils d'alain delon
est-ce que vous préféreriez être reconnu
par lui ou non il faudrait d'abord que
je sache qui est alain delon
voilà c'est très important si thierry
question suivant et vases des imprévus
que préféreriez vous avoir le brushing
de deuil le casier judiciaire de tapis
l'humour de ruka sous la santé du pape
alors ça c'est vrai que c'est une
question vraiment nul mais pas mal quand
même
est ce que tu veux vraiment que je
réponde oui alors torture moi oui plus
tard je ne répondrai pas comme ça ne
plaît pas du tout bien tu sais ça me
plaît vraiment pas cher ces personnes ne
me dit rien j'ai pas envie tu vois
consomme au dos comme ça bon bref ça va
ça ne me gêne pas oui
tapie ça me gêne profondément et l'autre
comme ils s'appellent vous casse au
cafop barokas que tu y travailles tu
sais comment tu l'appelles la santé du
papa non faut pas toucher il faut pas tu
te plais touche pas ce monsieur
daniel prévost oui j'en ai plein la
bombe à risque dans 5 minutes que faites
vous je la retarde
si vous deviez mourir dans un accident
d'avion
est-ce que vous préféreriez que ce soit
un avion d'air france de varig ou
d'égypte heures à très bien d'ailleurs
france varig ou egypte
oui d'après fériés quoi comme avion si
vous deviez moyen d'interaction à lyon
celui où je pourrai m'envoyer en l'air
bien que michel drucker maintenant est
ce que vous aimez les chiens avaient
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
alors à question politique maintenant
est-ce que vous préféreriez un président
de la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout oui on bien sûr c'était c'est une
question qui est totalement nulle
effectivement mais faut que je réponde
par une nullité du ça va être très dur
pour moi c'est dur de répondre par une
vérité non je préférerais pas d'élection
du tout franchement akkaoui acquis
accorderiez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à moi à moi a
tiré un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où
un jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles
c'est pas bien un vieux qui stocke des
jonas est pas bien non plus après tout
si les jeunes vrai moi je m'en fous je
m'en foutais un jeune qui tapent sur des
vieilles c'est pareil pour nous c'est
pas bien
du mois cherche midi éditeur
mieux c'est